PROFESSOR 1: This game is
inspired by Super Monkey Ball.
I don't know whether
you have played already.
PROFESSOR 2: So ready?
PROFESSOR 1: But
instead of a ball,
we had a real car, a car
with real physics in it.
But there's still one
problem which we didn't--
[AUDIENCE GASPING]
Right, it's hard.
[LAUGHING]
PROFESSOR 3: This
is acceleration,
and this is steering.
AUDIENCE: That's cool.
PROFESSOR 3: But it's
a bit complicated.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
The problem with this
is because each wheel
will exhibit its own torque.
So sometimes, it will
be quite unbalanced,
because the hand positions
are quite different,
and it will flip.
I tried to mitigate
it by attaching
a weight so that I can
lower the center of gravity.
It did some job, but
it wasn't perfect.
PROFESSOR 2: And I think
that this will work perfectly
if the terrain was
like the terrain
that you will have in a car.
Obviously, the physical-- where
we thought we'd reconsider.
AUDIENCE: This is like driving
on the moon in a Ferrari.
PROFESSOR 2: Exactly.
And this is because when I
was doing the level design
and testing, I was still
thinking about the ball.
If this was a ball rolling
down, it will be cute.
It will look like pinball.
And so what I need to do
next to improve it is I
need to change the level
design and make into a track.
Just a track, right?
AUDIENCE: Oh, that's
it flipping there.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
It's flipping too much.
AUDIENCE: It's trying
to roll like a ball.
[LAUGHING]
PROFESSOR 2: Well, that's
because the level is
pushing it.
That's exactly what's happening.
The level is--
AUDIENCE: Oh, so is there also
a force from behind on it?
PROFESSOR 2: No.
Actually, the level is
all concave-- or convex,
how do you say that?
AUDIENCE: Concave.
PROFESSOR 2: It's all concave.
It's like the level makes
the ball roll and do
these half-pipes, and
holes, and things like that.
But a car has four balls that
are going single-track, right?
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: Yay!
PROFESSOR 2: And it's
possible with a car.
There's this game
called [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Yeah?
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You could have, like,
for all of this, where you've
spend hours and hours
designing your amazing Ferrari,
but then the track
is set up to fall,
where this car spins around.
PROFESSOR 2: That's-- I
like that that's the result.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah, that's--
PROFESSOR 2: Oh, oh!
It's getting somewhere.
[LAUGHING]
[CLAPPING]
PROFESSOR 1: So
yeah, that's probably
the biggest problem we
have, because this level is
designed for a ball, not a car.
[LAUGHING]
So if you want to see
a level that we did--
PROFESSOR 2: That's the track.
[LAUGHING]
[CLAPPING]
We divided the labor,
and everybody went home.
And it was like OK, I
guess I need to do a level.
And then I did a level, but
I had a ball to test it.
I didn't have the car, because
the car was being worked on
at the time.
I actually-- we started a
completely new level that
is almost ready to
go, but it's for cars,
which means that there's no big
ramps, and falls, and so forth.
The shape it has is
like a bowl that you
put a marble inside it.
It's cute.
I mean, it's cute.
AUDIENCE: How did you
create the giant levels?
PROFESSOR 1: Blender.
PROFESSOR 2: In Blender.
AUDIENCE: In
Blender-- OK, so it's
a three-dimensional
object that just has
a rigid body attached to it.
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah, it's just
a mesh rigid-- rigid body.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wow.
PROFESSOR 2: Which-- that's
a big discovery, too,
because apparently,
there is a limit
in polygons to what a
mesh rigid body can have.
But also, if it's
too low resolution,
the physics don't work.
The edges are too sharp.
So I'm assuming that
if there's the need
to create a beautiful track,
a lot of the objects that
are the actual terrain-- they
need to be very low resolution,
and then this would be
a very fancy mesh on top
of it hiding it.
Which sounds obvious
now, but at the time.
PROFESSOR 1: May I
say, if you place
this track in a very
high resolution wall,
it also doesn't work.
It's just really jittery.
So I put this online
just to test my car.
And if I go forward,
it will go crazy.
The camera will go crazy.
So yeah, it doesn't really work.
[LAUGHING]
[INAUDIBLE] the keyboard.
I've never [INAUDIBLE] this.
PROFESSOR 2: But
you see this is more
like it should be-- the
level terrain should be more
like this.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
PROFESSOR 2: Not like
Super Monkey Ball.